In this lecture we return to the memory system
that we last discussed in Lecture 14 of Part
2.
There we learned about the fundamental tradeoff
in current memory technologies: as the memory's
capacity increases, so does it access time.
It takes some architectural cleverness to
build a memory system that has a large capacity
and a small average access time.
The cleverness is embodied in the cache, a
hardware subsystem that lives between the
CPU and main memory.
Modern CPUs have several levels of cache,
where the modest-capacity first level has
an access time close to that of the CPU, and
higher levels of cache have slower access
times but larger capacities.
Caches give fast access to a small number
of memory locations, using associative addressing
so that the cache has the ability to hold
the contents of the memory locations the CPU
is accessing most frequently.
The current contents of the cache are managed
automatically by the hardware.
Caches work well because of the principle
of locality: if the CPU accesses location
X at time T, it's likely to access nearby
locations in the not-too-distant future.
The cache is organized so that nearby locations
can all reside in the cache simultaneously,
using a simple indexing scheme to choose which
cache location should be checked for a matching
address.
If the address requested by the CPU resides
in the cache, access time is quite fast.
In order to increase the probability that
requested addresses reside in the cache, we
introduced the notion of "associativity",
which increased the number of cache locations
checked on each access and
solved the problem of having, say, instructions
and data compete for the same cache locations..
We also discussed appropriate choices for
block size (the number of words in a cache
line),
replacement policy (how to choose which cache
line to reuse on a cache miss),
and write policy (deciding when to write changed
data back to main memory).
We'll see these same choices again in this
lecture as we work to expand the memory hierarchy
beyond main memory.
We never discussed where the data in main
memory comes from and how the process of filling
main memory is managed.
That's the topic of today's lecture..
Flash drives and hard disks provide storage
options that have more capacity than main
memory, with the added benefit of being non-volatile,
i.e., they continue to store data even when
turned off.
The generic name for these new devices is
"secondary storage", where data will reside
until it's moved to "primary storage", i.e.,
main memory, for use.
So when we first turn on a computer system,
all of its data will be found in secondary
storage, which we'll think of as the final
level of our memory hierarchy.
As we think about the right memory architecture,
we'll build on the ideas from our previous
discussion of caches, and, indeed, think of
main memory as another level of cache for
the permanent, high-capacity secondary storage.
We'll be building what we call a virtual memory
system, which, like caches, will automatically
move data from secondary storage into main
memory as needed.
The virtual memory system will also let us
control what data can be accessed by the program,
serving as a stepping stone to building a
system that can securely run many programs
on a single CPU.
Let's get started!
Here we see the cache and main memory, the
two components of our memory system as developed
in Lecture 14.
And here's our new secondary storage layer.
The good news: the capacity of secondary storage
is huge!
Even the most modest modern computer system
will have 100's of gigabytes of secondary
storage and having a terabyte or two is not
uncommon on medium-size desktop computers.
Secondary storage for the cloud can grow to
many petabytes (a petabyte is 10^15 bytes
or a million gigabytes).
The bad news: disk access times are 100,000
times longer that those of DRAM.
So the change in access time from DRAM to
disk is much, much larger than the change
from caches to DRAM.
When looking at DRAM timing, we discovered
that the additional access time for retrieving
a contiguous block of words was small compared
to the access time for the first word,
so fetching a block was the right plan assuming
we'd eventually access the additional words.
For disks, the access time difference between
the first word and successive words is even
more dramatic.
So, not surprisingly, we'll be reading fairly
large blocks of data from disk.
The consequence of the much, much larger secondary-storage
access time is that it will be very time consuming
to access disk if the data we need is not
in main memory.
So we need to design our virtual memory system
to minimize misses when accessing main memory.
A miss, and the subsequent disk access, will
have a huge impact on the average memory access
time, so the miss rate will need to be very,
very small compared to, say, the rate of executing
instructions.
Given the enormous miss penalties of secondary
storage, what does that tell us about how
it should be used as part of our memory hierarchy?
We will need high associativity, i.e., we
need a great deal of flexibility on how data
from disk can be located in main memory.
In other words, if our working set of memory
accesses fit in main memory, our virtual memory
system should make that possible, avoiding
unnecessary collisions between accesses to
one block of data and another.
We'll want to use a large block size to take
advantage of the low incremental cost of reading
successive words from disk.
And, given the principle of locality, we'd
expect to be accessing other words of the
block, thus amortizing the cost of the miss
over many future hits.
Finally, we'll want to use a write-back strategy
where we'll only update the contents of disk
when data that's changed in main memory needs
to be replaced by data from other blocks of
secondary storage.
There is upside to misses having such long
latencies.
We can manage the organization of main memory
and the accesses to secondary storage in software.
Even it takes 1000's of instructions to deal
with the consequences of a miss, executing
those instructions is quick compared to the
access time of a disk.
So our strategy will be to handle hits in
hardware and misses in software.
This will lead to simple memory management
hardware and the possibility of using very
clever strategies implemented in software
to figure out what to do on misses.